c'est sans prendre c'est bon ça
normalement c 17 balles deux mois après
bonjour restos c'est peut-être avoir un
coût et une gamine j'ai des frais quoi
c'est bon c'est bon parce est passé est
passé
alors deux adultes un chien 53 c'est mon
disque et alors quoi et qui vient de
paris sa bonjour
voulez vous mettre à poil d'accord vous
allez vous faire [ __ ] ou pas
lens parce que c'est un supplément si
vous faites [ __ ] sur la plage alors
d'accord
non je regarde
annoncé une série d'ennemis que d'amis
renoncer seul vous regardez
[ __ ] ce mois ci d'un bal aura j'ai
jamais vu ça
voilà non non non non non allez-y
combien de jours vous êtes humains
celles faites attention les attentions
non c'est pas ça c'est que marcel a un
fils qui a été dans un hôpital
psychiatrique pendant 15 ans il est
sorti hier il a assassiné des touristes
qui dormait à la ferme il a été 15 en
hôpital psychiatrique
il est rentré hier donc la nuit vous
fermez la porte at les accords parce que
ce serait con là il est rentré hier ce
serait con qu un couple comme vous
égorgez la nuit rendez compte
by séparation moi jamais j'irai dans le
marché du jem attendait mais marcel il
est sympa mais le fils vous avez vu je
ne voulais pas lui rod et là c'est la
nuit qui sort sur touvre il s'enferme
dans la charte la journée il au premier
fermez bien mail et anti les ouvre avec
son que terre
un couple baya 15 ans qu'au début de
quand ils ont ouvert ou au camping à la
ferme quand les premières années il a
égorgé un couple de hollandais
il est il a violé la la voiture à voir
il a égorgé le couple de hollandais
il est malade ces mecs de quoi je parle
c'est mon frère alors est malade
il est sorti hier on verra ainsi vous
verrez ce soir s'il est guéri
allez bonne bourre je suis content nous
dira reconnais je pourrais le dire aux
journalistes bercy il fallait speaking
les lettones high rock you mother it's
my phone le sun is good ofac my mother
mais one shot my dick
non ok c'est sa grande le sort des 2,5
au hockey alors en poste avancé qu'il
connaissait et c'est quoi il c'est une
émission le
dimanche soir a commenté thierry
ardisson qui dirige les missions et oui
c'est partie de l'émission
non mais c'est une blague raciste ça
fait deux fois qu'on me dise à cette
semaine fait du micro-trottoir commandes
il intéresse des gens il leur pose des
questions d'ailleurs s'appeler fois
toujours aux gens mentalement ça c'est
quelque chose mais vous devez ressentir
vraiment vous ressemblez à laurent
bassiste comme a dit ils font des
saisies tu devrais aller faire le sosie
on l'a déjà dit ça il est sympa ce mec
on m'a dit que c'est un connard un peu
trop directe à l'embauché vos dit madame
oui si je crois mais si je le crois que
car par nature il serait un peu
prétentieux c'est un petit monsieur je
prends quelques connards cemac de la
télé jeux suivants pas ça on m'a dit
qu'ils étaient présents dans six mois
cela dit ces mecs là il faut trois
émissions ils prennent la grosse tête en
plus et c'est un mec arrogant
on m'a dit dans la voix c'est vrai je
lui ressemble mais vraiment sans les
lunettes ou vraiment ça se trouve c'est
moi ça se trouve un vous en dites quoi
havre ou le colleur prétentieux c'est
moi voilà hariri avec caméra là bas
c'était moi c'est moi
à